ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman.
And I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday,
and is available at
0 cost to everybody
on all standard feeds--
YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for
exciting research being
done at Stanford and elsewhere.
Research on human
beings that leads
to important
discoveries that assist
mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
the Huberman Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has agreed
to match that amount so now
we are able to double the
total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12 month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
So without further
ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question is
about colds and flus.
And the question
specifically is,
why is it that we get more colds
and flus in the winter months?
Is it the temperature outside?
Is it the fact that people are
spending more time indoors?
Or is it a myth that we get more
colds and flus in the winter
months?
Well, the first thing is that
the research very clearly
shows that in winter
months there is a greater
prevalence of colds and flus.
Now, of course, the words,
"in the winter months"
means many things.
For instance, in most areas
of the world unless you
live directly near the
equator, in the winter
months means that days
are going to be shorter
and nights are longer
than in the summer months.
In general, that's true.
It's of course,
especially true if you
live very far from the equator.
So imagine somebody living up
in Tromsø, Norway, which is
very close to the North Pole.
In winter, days are very,
very short in Tromsø.
And conversely in
the summer months,
days are very, very
long in Tromsø Norway.
Now, Tromsø Norway represents an
extreme of day length variation
according to time of year.
The closer you get
to the equator,
the less variation there is in
day length and therefore night
length across the year.
However, in most
locations on Earth,
days will be significantly
shorter by about an hour or two
at least for certain
parts of the year.
And in general,
shorter days correlate
with colder temperatures.
That's what's really
important to know,
which is that shorter days
generally correlate with colder
temperatures regardless of where
you live on the planet Earth.
OK.
So in the winter months
as we're calling it,
involves at least two things,
shorter days, which means what?
It means less sunlight
and either more artificial
light or more darkness depending
on how much artificial light
you rely on.
It also means, as we
mentioned, colder temperatures.
Colder temperatures, of
course, doesn't necessarily
mean that you are exposed
to those colder temperatures
because what's the third thing?
Shorter days and
colder temperatures
outside mean that people are
spending more time indoors.
So what the research
clearly shows
is that one of the reasons,
not the only, but one
of the reasons for the greater
prevalence of colds and flus
in the short days a.k.a.
winter months of the
year is that people
are spending more time
indoors and therefore
at closer proximity, which
raises a whole bunch of really
interesting questions
that have been explored
in the peer reviewed research
about proximity cold and flu
transmission.
There have been
studies for instance
where people come into the
laboratory who are suffering
from cold and flu and are
sneezing, having them sneeze
at different proximity
to other people,
obviously people are
doing this under consent.
They're agreeing
to participate in
these particular experiments.
And there does seem to be
a very nice relationship
between physical
distance between you,
the uninfected person,
and the sneezing,
coughing, nose
wiping, eye wiping,
we'll get into why I
mentioned all of those things
in a moment, person that
is suffering from the flu.
In other words,
the closer you are
to somebody who's
sneezing or coughing,
the higher probability that you
will contract that cold or flu.
OK.
So we've already
established two things.
First of all, physical
proximity is a key variable
in terms of transmission
of cold and flu.
And at some level that's a duh.
I mean, if you think about
it, if you're in the next room
or down the hallway from
or across the street
from somebody with
a cold or flu,
you don't expect to contract
that cold or flu from them.
Whereas if you're
in the same vehicle
with them or you're sitting
next to them on an airplane
or you are on the same bus or
in the same classroom as them
and they are sneezing
and coughing,
well, then, the probability that
you would get that cold or flu
from them is increased.
That's just obvious.
But the studies that have
explored the relationship
between physical proximity and
transmission of cold and flu
have actually analyzed things
down to the range of well,
if you're standing
one foot apart
or you're standing three
feet apart or six feet apart,
what's the probability that you
will contract that cold or flu?
And it follows a very
direct relationship
where the closer the
proximity, the more likely
that you're going
to contract the cold
or flu from that person.
And of course, anything like
exchange of skin contact
or exchange of saliva
because obviously in cases
of romantic relationships
where people will kiss
or in familial relationships or
friendships where people hug,
any contact also further
increases the transmission
of cold and flu.
Not just from stuff emitted
from the nasal passages
and from the mouth when
people sneeze and cough,
but also when people
wipe their eyes,
even when people wipe their
skin because oftentimes they
have cold or flu
virus on their skin.
It doesn't always survive
terribly long on the skin.
But if they wipe their
face or wipe their nose
or are using tissues
and then don't
wash their hands
thoroughly afterwards,
indeed they can transmit
cold and flu simply
through handshake.
OK.
So for all you
hypochondriacs out there,
I'm arming you with a
lot of useful knowledge
that will justify
staying away from people
who perhaps have cold and flu.
Now, this particular point
about proximity and people
being indoors more
during the winter months,
and that's why there's more
cold and flu transmission,
raises a whole bunch of
interesting questions,
and, in fact, protocols that I
plan to cover in a Huberman Lab
podcast episode solely
devoted to colds and flus
and how to avoid
getting colds and flus.
But one brief mention
or telegraph of what
I plan to cover
in that episode is
that if people are telling
you that they are sneezing
and coughing due to a cold or
flu but that they are quote
unquote "not contagious"
either because they
are early in the cold or flu
or late in the cold or flu
and they have these theories
or claims that oh, I'm
no longer contagious.
Keep in mind that any time
someone is sneezing or coughing
they are in fact contagious.
So I'll get back to
that in that full length
episode about colds and flus.
But I felt it was
too important not
to mention right now that
people's theories about when
they are quote
unquote "contagious"
or "not contagious" are
rarely substantiated
by the actual data.
The actual data
point to the fact
that when people are
sneezing and coughing,
if it's due to a cold or flu,
they are still contagious.
OK.
So we've established that
cold outside means people tend
to be indoors more
which increases
physical proximity, which
is one of the reasons
why there's more cold
and flu transmission.
One of the other reasons
why being indoors more
tends to increase cold
and flu transmission
is that in the cold months of
winter when people are indoors,
they tend to be not
under air conditioning,
not at neutral temperatures,
but rather they
tend to be in heated rooms.
And depending on
the type of heating
that's used, but in general,
due to all forms of heating,
the heated air tends
to be drier air.
Now, this is a little
bit counterintuitive
because if you ever go outside
on a really cold winter day,
you will realize
that the cold weather
outdoors is extremely dry.
You can almost quote unquote
"feel the dryness of the air."
And if you can't quote unquote
"feel the dryness of the air"
or imagine what that's
like just imagine this,
think of yourself outdoors
on a very cold winter
day taking a brisk walk.
Then think about yourself
taking that same brisk walk
on a very humid summer day.
Humidity is, of course,
the concentration
of water in the ambient
environment, the air,
whereas the dryness is
the lack of humidity.
And just that little simple
GedankenNet or thought
experiment will
remind you just how
dry the cold air is out of
doors during the winter months.
Whereas indoors we're
heating that air
and indeed the heating
of that air does
have the property of drying
the nasal and oral passages
but especially the
nasal passages.
So another key
reason why there's
more transmission of colds
and flus in the winter months
is because people are
spending more time indoors.
And oftentimes the way
those indoor environments
are being heated is drying
out the nasal passages.
And the nasal passages
represent a primary site
of defense for viral
infections like colds and flus
but also bacterial infections
and fungal infections
for that matter.
Now, I've talked before on this
podcast about the importance
of using nasal breathing
under any conditions where
you don't have to breathe
through your mouth.
So if you are not eating,
if you're not speaking,
or if you're not exercising
hard which by the way
oftentimes requires that you
breathe through your mouth.
There's nothing wrong with
breathing through your mouth
if you're exercising
hard and you
need to breathe
through your mouth
in order to bring
in enough oxygen.
There are conditions under which
that's entirely appropriate.
You can learn more about
that in the podcast episode
I did all about breathing
and breath work.
But for the most part it's
best to be a nasal breather
except under the conditions
I just mentioned.
Why?
Well, the nasal passages contain
a number of physical barriers,
including the hairs
within your nose.
I know that hairs in
the nose, especially
if they are super
numerous are not
considered aesthetically nice.
People will trim
them, et cetera.
But those hairs in
your nose actually
serve as a barrier
toward infection.
This is well established.
The lining of the nose, the
mucosal lining of the nose
contains a lot of things.
First of all, it acts as
its own physical barrier
and physical trap for incoming
viruses, fungal infections,
and bacterial infections.
They literally get trapped
in the nasal passages.
And therefore can't enter
deeper into your physiology.
And right now is
not the time to go
into the whole
anatomy and physiology
of the nasal passages.
But keep in mind if
you saw the episode
that I did with Noam Sobel
or you listen to the episode
that I did on olfaction,
both of those episodes
highlight the fact that
your brain sits not
far behind your nasal passages.
There's a bony barrier there
called the cribriform plate,
and there are some
other things as well,
but it's not far from your
nostrils to your brain.
And it is not far
from your nostrils
to the rest of your
respiratory pathway, of course.
And so the hairs of your
nostrils, the mucus itself,
and the microbiome,
the trillions
of little micro
bacteria that thrive
in the mucosal lining of
your nasal passages actually
serve to protect against many
of the incoming infections.
This is why it's so
important to keep
the mucosal lining of your nasal
passages thriving and intact.
How do you do that?
Well, one of the
best ways to do that
is to make sure that the
air that you're breathing
is sufficiently humidified.
So while there are many
different claims out there
about how to avoid
colds and flus,
as long as we're having a
discussion about why there
are more colds and flus
in the winter months
because indeed there
are, it's worth
mentioning that if you
suffer from colds and flus
and you're going to
spend a lot of time
in particular
indoor environment,
you might be wise to find a
air humidifier, something that
brings more moisture
into the air
that you're breathing especially
at night while you're sleeping.
Now, that's not going to prevent
the person in your environment
who happens to
have a cold or flu
and is sneezing actively from
transmitting that cold or flu.
But it will keep
your nasal passages
and the rest of your
respiratory pathways
as healthy as they can
be and as resistant
as they can be to
any colds or flues
that you might be fighting off.
And this is another
key point, which
is regardless of
whether or not it's
the winter months or the
other months of the year,
all day long you're combating
different types of infections.
Different types
of viral, fungal,
and bacterial infections
are bombarding your system
and your immune
system counters that
both through physical
and through neurochemical
and hormonal and pure
immune mechanisms.
OK.
There's a whole discussion
of this in the episode
that I did on the immune system.
We'll do more on this.
But keeping the air that
you breathe especially
at night sufficiently
humidified is one great way
to try and offset colds and
flus that you might be combating
because you brought
that cold or flu
home from work and your immune
system needs to ward it off.
OK.
If you are having a
hard time grasping
how it is that you could
bring home a cold or flu
and then ward it
off, do you have it?
Do you not have?
It is it sitting there trying
to get into your system?
Or do you have it a little bit?
Well, this is some
of the gray area
around cold and flu and
viral transmission generally.
I mean, we don't
know, for instance,
if you got a mild
sniffle as opposed
to a really bad cold
or flu whether or not
it would have been a
really bad cold or flu,
had you slept less, had you
not humidified your air better,
et cetera.
Probably it would be.
And if you've ever not
slept well for a little bit
and you're sick, you
experienced just how much worse
that sickness feels.
The symptoms of that sickness
go from very mild to moderate
or from mild to
moderate to very severe
when you are sleep deprived.
That said, it's also clear that
some strains of the cold or flu
can be more mild than other
strains of the cold or flu.
So this can be pretty nuanced.
And we'll go deeper
into this in the episode
that I do on cold and flu and
how to avoid cold and flu.
But nasal breathing whenever
possible day and night time
is extremely important for
encouraging the overall health
and resistance of
your respiratory
pathways to incoming cold and
flu and other types of viruses.
Similarly, humidifying the air
that you breathe especially
at night but perhaps also during
the day in your OFS environment
or home environment can also be
very beneficial for warding off
colds and flus.
And if you'd like to read more
about the nasal versus mouth
breathing components
of colds or flus,
I'll just mention one
paper now and again, I'll
go into this in more depth in
the future episode on colds
and flus.
But I want to mention that
this is a bidirectional effect,
meaning people who deliberately
breathe through their nose
tend to get fewer
colds and flus.
Also people who tend to
breathe through their mouth
more tend to get
more colds and flus.
Now, you might think that's
the same thing or just
two sides of the same coin.
But actually it's not.
There's what we call a
double dissociation whereby
if people are mouth
breathers, they
are far more susceptible
to colds and flus
and other types of
respiratory illnesses.
I'll put a link to
one particular paper
that I like a lot in the
show note captions entitled
association of oral breathing
with dental malocclusions
and general health in children.
This paper explores a
lot of different things
about nasal versus mouth
breathing all of which,
by the way point
to the fact that
nasal breathing whenever
possible is better for us
health wise, aesthetically,
dental health wise
than is mouth breathing.
But one of the key
components here and this is
why I bring it up in the
context of this discussion
is quote "oral breathing is
related to a significantly
higher prevalence of allergies
and a significantly more likely
getting sick and taking
medication for being sick."
OK.
So lots in this study,
lots in related studies.
But nonetheless, being a nasal
breather, humidifying your air,
paying attention
to whether or not
you're indoors with people
who are coughing and sneezing
because it's cold outside,
all of those things
are going to be
relevant perhaps keeping
a little bit of distance,
maybe a lot of distance
from those people or encouraging
them to wash their hands
after they wipe their nose.
Maybe even sending them to a
little bit of not necessarily
isolation although
that might be necessary
but keeping them at a distance.
I don't think it's too
much to ask somebody
who's sick to not get you sick.
Personally I think that's the
polite thing to try and do.
And there's actually
not many things ruder
than someone who
knows that they're
sick showing up to something
because they didn't want
to miss that particular event
and getting everybody else sick
frankly, that's my opinion.
I think that opinion is
shared with many of you
out there as well.
Now, as I mentioned earlier,
when it's cold outside,
the air tends to be drier.
Not always.
I mean, you could live
in an environment that's
very cold and very rainy,
obviously very rainy
is very humid.
It's maximum humidity
if you think about it.
But if you are going
to spend time out
of doors in cold days of
winter, which by the way,
is a really good thing
for other reasons,
I'll get into those
reasons in a moment
because they relate
directly to why there's
such a prevalence
of colds and flus
because in general,
people are not doing what
I'm about to tell you to do.
But there are two things
to keep in mind if you're
going to be out of doors.
First of all, the things
about proximity still hold.
There have been
studies of people
who have colds and flus
sneezing in indoor environments
versus outdoor environments and
how much transmission there is.
Again, it boils
down to proximity.
Yes, you can get a cold or
flu from somebody sneezing out
of doors next to
you just as well
as you can if they
sneeze next to you
indoors There's a slightly
higher probability that you'll
get it from them if they're
sneezing at that same distance
but you're indoors as opposed
to outdoors obviously sneezers,
coughers-- sneeze and cough
in the other direction,
cover your mouth and nose.
If you don't have a tissue
or something, we are told
and I subscribe to the idea
that sneezing into your elbow
or coughing into your elbow
is probably the next best
thing to not covering up at all,
as opposed to into your hand,
which then you touch
other things and yourself.
Anyway, without getting into
the mechanics of sneezing
and coughing too
deeply, if you're
going to be outside in
the cold winter months
and you'd like to avoid getting
colds and flus, when you run,
when you exercise,
when you walk,
when you're in conversation,
try to nasal breathe unless you
have to mouth breathe.
And if you can sense your
nasal passages or your mouth
drying out because of
that hard breathing,
and by the way exercise
during the winter
months is still important.
So I'm not discouraging people
from exercising outdoors
during the winter months as
long as you can do it safely.
But if you feel those
air passages drying out,
just be aware that when
you take those dried out
air passages in doors and
you're around other people that
might have colds
and flus, you are
going to be more susceptible.
So that's cause for taking a
hot shower, perhaps if you have
access to a steam
room or humidifier,
and rehydrating those
nasal and oral passages.
Now, if you're
outside and running
and you're breathing hard and
your nasal passages are drying
out, does that mean that you're
more susceptible to colds
and flus that are just
out in that environment
if no one else is around?
Chances are no.
However, what we
were all told when
we were kids which is if you
go outside and you get a chill,
it's a good idea when
you come back inside
to take a hot
shower or a hot bath
or if you have access to
it a sauna to heat back up.
That's also true, why?
Well, it does seem that
there's a relationship
between core body temperature
and susceptibility
to cold and flu.
And this is something
I'm going to go
deeply into in the
episode on colds and flus.
Keep in mind that fevers that
are the response to exposure
to a cold or flu or being full
blown sick with a cold and flu
are an attempt of your immune
system to heat up that virus
and destroy it.
Keep that in mind if
you're considering
taking any medication to
lower your fever, of course,
know that highly elevated
body temperatures a.k.a. fever
can be very dangerous
to the brain and body.
There's a fairly
limited upper range
of temperatures that we
can go into before we
start damaging ourselves.
But also keep in mind that
fever is an adaptation designed
to destroy viruses.
So if you blunt the
fever, you are actually
letting a cold or
virus to proliferate
more readily than it
would if you allowed
a slight fever to combat that.
OK.
So there's a whole discussion to
be had there because obviously
you don't want people
cooking their brains
due to elevated fever and
not treating that fever.
But you also don't want
to reduce your core body
temperature too much which
raises the question of things
like cold plunges.
Should you be
taking cold showers
and doing cold plunges
in the winter months
when it's already cold and
you're susceptible to colds
and maybe you're coming
down with a cold,
should you do that?
Well, that segues
into the next question
that I'm going to answer
for this AMA, which relates
directly to cold exposure
and so-called cyclic
hyperventilation breathing
sometimes associated
with so-called Wim Hof breathing
but other forms of deliberate
breathing as well.
And how specific forms of
deliberate breathing and how
deliberate cold
exposure can indeed
be used to offset or even
prevent entirely infection
due to bacterial or viruses.
But if you're
already coming down
with a bacterial
or viral infection,
why cyclic hyperventilation
breathing or why deliberate
cold exposure may actually
be the worst thing
if you are already contracting
or have contracted,
if you are contracting or
have already contracted
a cold or virus.
So we'll answer
that question next.
In the meantime, just know
that yes, indeed in the winter
months you are more
susceptible to colds and flus
because there's more
of them going around.
We talked about some of
the reasons why they're
going around, and
some of the things
you can do to protect yourself
against those colds and flus.
There are a bunch
of other things
that you can do that are very
valuable that will explore
in the full length
episode on colds and flus
and how to avoid getting them.
And I'm hoping you all
stay clear of colds
and flus these winter months.
And now you have some
tools to try and reduce
the duration and severity
of those colds and flus
should you get one.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which,
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast
and to fund research.
In particular research
done on human beings
so not animal models
but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is a species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the research
that provides those answers
in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do dollar
for dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again, there's a
cost of $10 per month
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]